you agreed to come out here so that we
could just kind of digress and
decompress and make progress on what's
Happening so let's Play that video real
quick
[Music]
and he's a good man we've been married
for a long time now but sometimes he can
be too much like the other night I saw
him yelling at the microwave popcorn's
not pizza you [__]
he's doing too much Dr Phil can you
please help him
does she ever stop bitching
you know it's like if I got a thousand
Rogue gigs a year am I am I doing too
much no that's just fine you can drag
your ass on another United flight she
doesn't give a [__]
go up to the top of the globe where
there's [__] wildfires and [__]
polar bears walking around falling to a
bunch of drunk Canadians in a park he
thinks she gives a [__] I don't think
she does she's out getting her nails
done
well [__] me